ALICIA WILLIAMS:
Today, we're talking
about BigQuery, VMware Engine,
ML, and carbon emissions.
I'm Alicia, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Last year, we announced our most
ambitious sustainability goal
yet, to operate
everywhere on 24/7 carbon
free energy by 2030.
Since setting our target,
we've made tremendous progress
in how we track, buy, and
use electricity, advocate
for clean energy
policies, and support
the development of
new technologies
to help us reach this goal.
And in the spirit
of transparency,
we've released some
further information
about our 2020 consumption.
The "A Year in
Carbon Free Energy"
animation points out
significant projects
that came online in 2020 to
bring our data centers closer
to operating entirely on
round-the-clock carbon
free energy.
Check it out on the blog.
With all the updates from
Google Cloud VMware Engine,
we've devoted a whole blog post
to breaking them down for you.
As a teaser, Google
Cloud VMware Engine
delivers an enterprise-grade
VMware stack running natively
in Google Cloud.
This Cloud service is
one of the fastest paths
to the Cloud for
VMware workloads,
without making changes
to existing applications
or operating models across
a variety of use cases.
Head over to the
blog post for more.
The latest round of ML
perf benchmark results
have been released, and
Google's TPU v4 supercomputers
demonstrated record-breaking
performance at scale.
These scores are a significant
improvement over our winning
submission from last
year, and demonstrate
that Google once again has
the world's fastest Machine
Learning supercomputers.
These TPU v4 pods are
already widely deployed
throughout Google data centers
for our internal Machine
Learning workloads, and will
be available via Google Cloud
later this year.
If you haven't yet, check out
our new BigQuery spotlight
series, where
throughout the summer,
we'll be adding new videos
and blog posts focused
on helping new BigQuery
architects and administrators
master the fundamentals.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.